[Music]
to go that fast with that much lean
angle that's basically an immediate
crash hi my name is casey stoner i'm a
former motogp world champion in my
career i managed to win two motogp world
championships today we're looking at
motorcycle scenes from movies and
judging how real they are
[Music]
motorcycle with one hand isn't difficult
at all but with your opposite hand is
very difficult as soon as you look
around and look back quite often you
veer offline and there's people that can
ride and do wheel stands and stoppies
while riding backwards and side saddle
and all that sort of other thing
but it takes a heck a lot of practice
and it's not at those speeds while while
trying to sword fight
[Music]
yeah there's not a whole lot of um of
realism
in that one trying to get something
through a wheel when it's spinning that
fast is nearly impossible if anything
happens to the back wheel it certainly
doesn't cause the front to come up and
go now if something gets lodged in the
front wheel that will happen you know
the back will come up and go over the
front
[Applause]
it was uh was quite realistic wet white
lines the way we explain it in racing
it's like ice as soon as you come across
a white line that's not painted with a
special grip it's literally just as soon
as you touch it you know you're pretty
much gone if you know you're going to
crash or you know you're going to hit
something a lot of the time the best way
is either just to lay the bike down
because a low side or a front end lose
there's going to be a lot less
complications when you have a high side
which is when you lose the rear end and
then it creates grip again and then it
flicks you over the high and
basically it sends you up in the air so
when you go what goes up must come down
and it's a lot more painful and i
definitely had a little more experience
than i'd like i would say probably a two
[Music]
eyes would be watering
that's uh that's for sure you know the
no helmet thing would be probably the
most difficult aspect any little bits of
dust a rock flicking up off a car off
the bike in front almost impossible a
lot of the stuff he does
we do that basically to get a feeling of
where the ground is it gives us an
understanding of where our lean angles
are and things like that now without a
knee slider it's doing very little other
than to take a bit of skin off
i've seen bikes explode as these are
kind of standard road bikes the
temperatures are so high um especially
around the head of the exhaust
that
it really can ignite quite a lot
so the shifting is something to be
brought up a little you don't need to to
do a clutch that's a very very old um
system to basically ease the bike in a
little bit easier and a little bit
smoother into gear unless you're going
back gears going into a corner you don't
need to use a clutch on modern bikes
these days we have something called a
quick shifter now so it cuts the power
to the engine for a second allows the
the bike to to reduce a little bit of
torque so that the gear can turn can
select and then they can keep going
the crash was was pretty fine you know
losing the front in that situation i
guarantee he would have a little bit of
meat missing down the down the side of
his body as soon as you touch tarmac it
loves to to rip apart whatever you've
got even with leathers on but overall
because he slid onto the gravel as well
uh it would have been a little softer
than sliding the whole way on tarmac i'd
probably rate this scene around an eight
[Music]
of course there's always a key in the
bike you know they go and get on and
just start and off it goes
i mean going upstairs on a bike uh
realistically isn't very hard at all
even for myself who's not a technical
rider like this they actually have that
as part of a race going up them and down
them and they're actually racing through
the streets
[Music]
riding across the top of that small gap
uh would have been the most difficult
part of that whole scene as easy as it
seems when you're going at that speed
one little mistake can be quite
catastrophic so getting those gaps would
have been
would have been definitely a little bit
tricky at those speeds you know they
were doing a very very good job on that
scene
[Music]
it's not that hard to do those sort of
jobs actually the faster you go the
better it is
the slower you go the the more straight
down you sort of go but you come down
and you
you land
flat from too high of a point can break
your wrists break your ankles if you hit
the seat as well people have broken
their backs and things so
it can be quite tricky you know those
drops were realistic you can do that but
yeah it starts getting bigger than that
then some injuries start to happen it'd
probably be a nine pretty incredible
what people can do on bikes especially
these days they just keep pushing the
limits
they actually had a key this time they
got it right with that they needed a key
to start the bike
jumping off the truck might have been
possible with a with a motocross bike or
an off-road bike but with a road bike
with two people on it as soon as they
landed it just would have bounced them
and
high sided or something you know that
basically is nearly impossible for that
to happen
[Music]
the burnout turning around yes that's
possible the the way they were just
sitting there and doing it especially
with two people on board and you've got
a lot of weight over the rear tyre it's
quite hard to then get it to spin around
a lot of the whole burnouts and then
taking off from there basically being
like a boost that's not the case it's a
negative for us if you've ever seen
somebody do burnouts and you have a look
at that tyre afterwards there's a big um
flat part of the tyre because you've
basically just melted the rubber off it
and we don't want it flat we need to
keep a round surface with cars you kind
of do need to do a burnout sometimes to
try and heat the tire through
a lot of movies get this wrong but this
one in particular is the fact that cars
can just catch them so quickly there's
very few supercars that can go as quick
as what bikes can
uh especially a ducati you know that's
top of the line at the time bikes have
acceleration that's incredible you know
it's basically 160 180 kilo bike
uh for 200 plus horsepower the ratio is
extreme and when they've got cars that
can just zoom right up to them that's
that's probably the most unrealistic
part
[Music]
the riding to the traffic and everything
at the beginning wasn't too bad i think
with two people on it's uh it's
unrealistic you can't change direction
that quickly you know road bikes the
faster you go the harder it is to change
direction if they're going at the speeds
that they're implied those maneuvers
just aren't possible the stunt riders
they've got to have cars coming along
with them so they're restricted to what
speed they can do and when they're going
slower it's actually quite hard to have
good form as if you were doing those
fast scenes so
it's very tricky thing to do and that's
why i was impressed with the mission
impossible because you're actually able
to
see they've got quite good form all
through that scene they've got quite
good styles and everything like that so
i would rate this
a three or a four again the fact that
they had a key i really liked that
aspect
harleys in general are a little
difficult to ride they're everything's
so low slung and it's quite actually
hard to get them to uh to corner at the
best of times harley's actually can have
quite a lot of horsepower i mean they're
incredible machines as soon as you you
go down through any kind of dip or curb
it's not going to like it
[Music]
there's no way a big bike like that
wouldn't just land and go into a ton of
pieces and if it was real i mean i don't
think they have much of a back left so
that's quite hard for me to
to see actually happening
a big heavy bike like that you know
landing from that sort of drop only a
dirt bike could make that drop and it's
still going to hurt a bit i would say
3 4 again there's parts of it that were
that were realistic enough
[Music]
drifting on a motorcycle on road bikes
definitely possible to go that fast with
that much lean angle that's basically an
immediate crash
uh at those sort of speeds and for me at
that angle is just sort of not possible
there's going to be no more grip and and
the bike will go away from underneath
you there's lots of elements again we're
talking about on the street as well so i
was on a race track you've got
consistent grip levels etc etc
but this is the first time seeing it on
a street there's oil spills all that
it's going to be very difficult to
manage and judge those situations so i
would say that's nearly impossible
that's not a problem to do that and
create a stoppie the distance that she
did it in though was probably
unrealistic because to to do a stop he
actually makes you stop slower
um if you've got the rear wheel let's
say a foot off the ground that's not too
bad that's at about your braking limit
because there's a certain force and
angle and everything as soon as you
start going too far
then that force is carrying you over the
top for someone to stop that quick with
a stoppie it's it's not realistic
[Music]
it's electric bikes so they don't have
clutches just use a throttle with an
electric bike which again would probably
make the uh
the burnout that she did quite difficult
as well i would say
again three four marks
riding with two people doing something
different is is nearly impossible it'll
be easier to ride one-handed than it
would be um to ride with two people like
that for two people to just jump on and
one use the clutch and the left
handlebar and one use the the throttle
and break on the right unless you've
practiced day in day out with someone
to do something like that's you know
that's impossible
the the noise of this bike there's no
way a big bike like that it's going to
be that quiet it sounded very much like
a scooter so many scenes you'll see a of
two strokes that sound like a
four-stroke they just you know they
haven't quite got it right and this one
um almost sounds like a scooter that's
taking off you know it certainly doesn't
sound like a harley of that big bike
that they're actually riding
[Applause]
doing a wheelie like that on that bike
is is it's not impossible big heavy bike
like that you're going to struggle to
really get the power it's long and the
balance point is very very uh it's it's
quite bad on those sort of bikes you
know they're made to stay on the ground
they're not made to get the front wheel
in the air so i've seen people that can
wheelie just about anything
but um yeah i would say again that's a
very very low probability to be able to
do that wheelies do not help you go
faster the amount of times i see them
drop back a couple of gears and run and
then chuck a wheelie and all of a sudden
they're flying along it's not faster um
all of your your weight then is going up
it's the same with the stoppie scene if
you've got your weight going down it's
it's wanting to overtake you but with a
wheelie up here you can't accelerate you
can't get going because basically the
bike wants to to keep going the other
way so wheelies especially in racing is
our enemy uh occasionally you can come
up and control it but it has to be no
more than six or eight inches off the
ground
um and that's where you find that sort
of balance point you get any further
than that it wants to start overtaking
you and then you have to start backing
off so unless you're throwing a wheelie
i guess to stop some bullets you know
hitting you as uh as we've seen in quite
a few
uh yeah there's there's no way wheelies
are helping you out
of course the jump is impossible and
going through a roof and surviving it
and not breaking your backs on just the
impact that one was very very difficult
to to see the realism in and i'd
probably go
one or two
i know the the rider who actually
did that and ridden with him personally
and and know that everything's possible
that's in that movie so you know there's
there's nothing unrealistic for me there
the jump that he made up the up the wall
is definitely possible he had you know
small amount of ramp there from the curb
the key to getting up uh heights like
that it's all loading the body loading
the bike loading the tires and
suspension all at the right moment so
they use that little pop that ramp for
the front end to get that up and to get
over a wall like that you can't just
clean jump it so basically they're using
their rear tyre
they're jumping up as far as they can
keep the front tire over the top of it
and then they use their rear to ride up
the last bit and then that helps the
front clear and then they use their
momentum to get over so everything that
he did was was
you know 100 real so 10 out of 10. they
kept themselves in a realistic state
there so i like that one
steve mcqueen's an absolute legend and i
think did most of his own stunts ever on
a bike and things like he was he was
just incredible you know there was no
special effects or anything like that
that was
a clean you know honest jump and
everything grass isn't too bad if you've
got off-road tyres
knobbies you know if they're fresh and
have sharp edges
grass really isn't too bad to ride on
gives you a fair bit of grip but on the
type of bike he was on with those tyres
there wouldn't have been a whole lot of
grip it was nice to see a couple little
slide outs there things like that
because it was you know lush green grass
it ends up being um very very slippery
but you know to be honest quite a lot of
fun the jump definitely possible
everything plausible so yeah i'd have to
give it a 10.
[Music]
the sparking boots is something that
they would have made or designed it
could just be a few screws
that they put around the edge of the
boots we started to do a night race in
qatar
and during the night race when i was
racing ducati we had
quite low foot pegs the way our bike was
designed and everything so during the
daytime you couldn't see it sparking but
at night time because i was touching the
foot pegs on one of the corners and the
track it would spark quite a lot it's
not too difficult to get to get some
sparks happening at night time
[Music]
the wheelies were all were all possible
uh the stoppies were possible it's all
more than plausible it's all stuff i can
do myself so
if i can do it definitely there's some
people out there that can do a heck of a
lot more than that the one thing that i
probably couldn't do was when he did the
handstand
they only used the clutch when they were
going back gears
they weren't going too fast doing
everything
everything and every maneuver they did
was plausible everything's um realistic
there i'd have to say yeah 10 out of 10.
if you enjoyed this video
click here to watch another one